we have hit the moment in the show and I
share something awesome from social
media you may have missed you're welcome
this is what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
musical force to be reckoned with she's
played piano at some of the most
renowned venues out there including
Carnegie Hall I'm not too shabby but her
favorite performances aren't on Grand
stages actually they're at her local
Senior Center or playing virtually for
Frontline workers and hospital patients
right here in New York check her out in
action
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you look beautiful you need to know that
you look stunning how long have you been
playing I've been playing when I was
only three and a half years old I have
perfect pitch I can remember the melody
and copy it by my hand I love playing
the piano
oh my gosh
I love you oh so so what do you love
about playing for seniors and patients
because I can make people happy I still
remember that one day after I finished
my playing a senior came up to me and
humped me tiny and said honey you made
my day you are my sunshine I saw tears
in her eyes and I knew that it was happy
tears
oh my gosh
Lala at some point you've got to come in
the studio and you got to play I want to
sing with you I just go I just want to
hang out with you you make me so happy
God what a gift you are
thank you so much Lily I'm liking your
posts right now
and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin the go-to pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show likes to celebrate
those who create fearlessly just like
you uh so they'll be using their
friction erasable pen to write you a
check for a thousand dollars
[Applause]
[Music]